right give that shirt to Theo yeah oh
it's a medium huh sighs he was ya know I
feel like he's a large there he is yeah
let's do it
we're ready let's do it Brian the kid
Callen is missing in action today
actually he's in Denver with his family
Senior Olympics sir Senior Olympics oh I
sent out the bat signal for the uh I
mean last year's guest of the year the
man who took over our last studio
reigning defending not much good to be
here deal barn in the house good to see
you guys today on fight on the kids much
younger more handsome a little bit of a
southern twang and a mullet who may
talent yeah this isn't a mullet first of
all gender-neutral haircut
it's the only way I'm getting work these
days with this haircut bro you know and
you love look I don't know what you'd
call mine you know I got my hair cut in
San Jose and it might like this
old-school like gangster dude he goes
bro you look like John Gotti now well I
don't know if that's the look I'm going
for Matt murderers cut yeah he goes he
goes everyone wants to do this because I
was getting a fade you know I get faded
up usually high and tight yeah and he
goes that's what the kids are doing man
you let me do it proper I'll make you
look like Mad Men yeah he gave you that
prison cut yeah I was again I don't want
that man but I just shut my mouth and
took it yeah well that step for
definitely that prison cut thing were
you getting who are you you know that I
get my cut locally here and I get mine
cut uh almost anywhere I am I'll get it
cut locally I prefer local cuts great
coops yeah it's like a local
establishment where people are
struggling you know cuz I like when
somebody cuts my hair if it looks bad
and I look at the person that cut it and
they look like [ __ ] I'm like you know
that's how it works that's of this role
yeah cuz how do you tell them you like
hey tie down the sides party in the back
and he's in the front well you know I
got here is you I got hair rejuvenation
surgery
yeah I got part of my mullet taken out
and put in the front and no one's ever
done that ever ever I don't think and I
didn't need it no you don't need you
have great has even grown in yet either
oh oh so we're waiting for it yeah what
are you gonna do it's gonna grow in your
eyes bangarang Brom have banks forever
dude I'm gonna rescue rescue rescue an
orphans off of airships bro I'm gonna be
Rufio II what yeah I don't know it we'll
see man I'm excited about you know the
thing is I have this man that cuts it
and he how much you charge you for a
nice cut like that probably nineteen
fifty or almost 20 that's a good deal
$18 when I met him him a tip yeah I give
him six to eight dollars solid tip I
think cash yeah let's unload tip him
credit Penn on how I'm feeling and
what's going on with him and how a man
his wife always fighting so if I've to
hear about that [ __ ]
four dollars I agree hey I met your
therapist say that [ __ ] I got my own
problems man I'm not up there but
someone got with a bad haircut
yeah and how often do you see him mmm we
text a little bit he's in oh he's a real
moody ah there's the only new guy yeah
you're that loyal oh yeah man yeah that
golden retriever dude
all right you know what I'm saying I'll
lay by his grave when he dies but next
to a pair of scissors
yeah you know I'm be a video on you on
Facebook look what the golden retriever
did he'll never forget the man that used
to trim him and he runs out there but
even though he's a shitty barber you
just [ __ ] ride and died with his dude
he's horrible dude and he has the
smallest head - this man is the smallest
had nice to date a girl with a small
head when I was in when I was in my 20s
and this girl the smallest head did and
her hair made it look like her head was
regular-sized like them it's tiny but if
you would start like kissing her and
touching my grabbing her head or
anything could almost yeah
you could almost you could touch like
the back of like the base of her neck
like that little part that end in in the
back of her neck and then all the way in
between the front of her eyes just a
little tiny mouse he thought and then
regular body regular body it was like is
like the movie Beetlejuice where they
sprinkle you man she had that regular
body but she had that uh yes she had
that real just
I don't know what kind of head it was
just yeah tiny head tiny brain
did you ever it really never been with a
girl when you you feel their head you
can feel the tracks like the oh yeah put
in now girls do tracks almost yeah it's
almost even white girls it's like a wee
but they put it in there
I like the traps I like the tracks you
know you feel like you can feel around
in there and maybe find a bag of dope or
something you know I don't like it you
don't know yeah leave that [ __ ] natural
well it used to be more of like maybe
only people only hooked up with like an
urban chick you know you would find that
you didn't find some I care extensions
that's more to everyone now everybody's
got it everybody's trying to be Rihanna
even the [ __ ] you know you'll see
like a you'll see a girl have no you
know can't afford any clothes or
anything children starving and she got
[ __ ] you know forty dollars with the
hair tied into her bra I've seen this on
the podcast yesterday with Kalin I was
in San Jose doing shows during the day
now did you walk around get coffee do it
like you do I'm walking there's this
most people work but yeah yeah go ahead
so there's this there's this mom on the
sidewalk with two she's homeless and she
was Indian with two small kids I felt
bad for you to cash but then there's
some dude slip my DMS today I guess he's
part of the San Jose Police Department
something like that and was I forget
what he does something with dangos dude
she's been there for like two years
we've seen those kids come up with her
it's all a bolo on Indian her husband
picks her up does a decent car got a
bolo on fake Indians they're in San Jose
I mean you're not gonna influence Indian
children do it I don't think a lot of
Indian kids like it to be like I wanna
[ __ ] you know look like a French Paul
Bunyan when I get older no I'm saying do
you look like Paul Bunyan if you just
drank champagne all day and never did
any forestry because Ram you don't know
yourself that well you gotta get a
better mirror man using [ __ ] cheap
mirrors you got $111 socks and cheap
mirrors dude Wow bro
man you got to get out more
ladies and mirrors as regular beer I
need two new mirrors you've been raised
in a clown house house our house our new
store how's our old studio working out
for you
first of all you guys up up some dirty
shoes that I guess some woodworker made
you got it fried some shoes shoes is
some [ __ ] cobbler yeah because this
dude goes yo we're always brought
Brendan's oh he's make for your shoe so
I made these myself for you the bride
goes because I always get package any
brain does it brian is finally got my
own package
check these out oh it looks like a
Chinese art class final project that's
what it looks like all the loops for the
shoelaces are all like different real
hairs human hair
[Laughter]
we kept them in for a little bit I tried
to put one of them on cut off all blood
[ __ ] my feet dude
I think they have anthrax in the soles
or something because my feet hurt for
like the next probably 36 hours
and they're like a shitty oh yeah I
don't know if it's leather might be
human skin
yeah it's stiff it looks a little yeah
it looked a little Polynesian Oh bro you
know and some of the a leather had acne
on and I'm like I think this is human
skin you know you see how shoes don't
have moles on the side of them yeah and
then there are sunspots
and then they painted the leather like a
brown
it seeps down into like the souls of
this Jew oh [ __ ] oh you take a picture
of those so yeah just put some yes and
they didn't been the problem is you put
them on you can't move you can't you're
basically ice skating with no blades
that's what it's like I think I sneeze
don't have like any comfort or cushion
them yeah ah Guinea bottoms I think I'm
like it's a small slit through there
like very small boats look at something
no what would have made if you were
there's a homosexual oh you know they
look like like like little animals would
just jump on the on the tops of each one
work show so you have left that and what
else has been in there that's it man
it's coming along dude it's hot you get
some some plants in there and [ __ ] your
talk about some plants we got it we just
got a grow lamp in today we found a $30
grow lamp on Amazon and a couple of
Porthos ferns you know why cause man we
want to get that we want to get just a
little bit more foliage in there you
know we're running on that trying to get
a little bit more nature in there I like
that yeah greening up a little bit yeah
we're trying to get like a little bit of
ivy you know have kind of like an IV
kind of that's where you walk in and
that's cool this is gonna take a while
yeah it's cool vibe this import those
plants right there a thing what do they
got there how much does run 17 dollars
17 bucks but here's the thing they're
small you have to [ __ ] raise them uh
and then you got to put that light on
them once you grow a little marijuana in
there I got some weed in there if we can
get somebody that knows more about it
yeah I wouldn't mind growing a little
bit of weed maybe soon and that's some
of the fans yeah selling it yeah the
field strength at strain boy a straight
hug makes you just it'll cure Down
syndrome bro I beat it it was a lot of
rumors in my town I got beat down
syndrome yeah well that's inspiring man
that's how I felt when I heard him
because I didn't start them and that's
one of the things that's beautiful about
sometimes being in a small town is you
know it doesn't take long for you to
hear [ __ ] about yourself
yeah you get more feedback yeah in LA
some guy walks through by in the hall
like aw look at this [ __ ] gym pain
you know but you never know you never
hear but in a small towns only nine
people I know we hear it now though
these days social media yeah
bicha you get a lot of haters on there
I'm sure I'm sure I don't see a lot of
it but I'm sure do you um I don't think
so I mean I get I get some stuff I guess
but I don't think anything I really
trying to think of something I'm tough
to hate on you cuz you're not really
like I'll get like I'll get some hate
obviously one of my are easier to hate
it well you think I mean there's just
more I mean like if I know you know you
look bro you only think about exactly
what you look like dude you like
somebody drinks keels at the airport do
you look like a troubled man uses drinks
and all bottles of keels hand lotion at
the airport you got issues man
uh-huh you start seeing our brother
[ __ ] you need to see artists we end
here draw something
mock up a decent image and you look like
Lenny from Of Mice and Men but if we're
filmed in like like if it were film
probably more film they look like the
biggest [ __ ] kid in Sacramento
fro and that's true dude and I mean them
and I don't mean that in a mean way
right there Lenny small right there run
like straight up nice jack dude you look
at you you're like - dude who if
everybody's escaped in prison you'd be
like now I gotta I gotta be up in the
morning for breakfast saying like you
need to do this like doesn't get that
everybody I probably do didn't have
makeovers run from did I remember my mom
actually want a perm one time on the
radio that was you and some other [ __ ]
from across town said it was hers
I don't just be from Louisiana well I
mean it's a hit-or-miss state you know
it has a lot of that dark magic mullets
are not frowned upon
actually the go yeah it's just a goatee
for the back Ian necks I uh I was just
saying man I was just here in Louisiana
this weekend doing shows
yeah I know crawfish boil hanging out
with family what happened man the show's
down there go I'm assuming since you're
a hometown boy the show's down there are
pretty crunk oh no it's not that good
man it's like you know like we as it is
but as New Orleans a good spot for
comedy no and I felt my comedy special
down there and it was a you [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up why did you do it done there I
just saw it like I was exciting
family will get to see it and everybody
will get to comment to be easy for my
family to call my friends to come this
is the Netflix whoa yeah
and they just didn't I mean the
production company was not good but it
was uh it just the the audience didn't
know how to they didn't know what was
going on one lady was all dressed out an
LSU [ __ ] you know and she's yelling
defense half of this shut up throw her
out
get the [ __ ] yeah oh yeah I feel like
the hometowns not the way to go to shoot
a special it wasn't it wasn't man so
when you go back do you have like weird
feelings we go back to Louisiana you
know because you're born there there's
some things like people know you as far
as like your failures there or your
success but yeah when you go back like
Rogan our time outs in Boston sometimes
you have the mentality when you were
broke and people were like now I saw
this dude you know when he's dead [ __ ]
broke right and this I saw him fail at
this song bomb here so I'm there so when
you go there especially when I go to
Denver I have a different vibe about me
mmm where's my hometown I love it and
there's some great memories but there's
also like oh I feel that this year I did
this there I did this you think about
this here oh you feel a little bit more
of like kind of not your old self but is
more of an element in here in like your
moments yeah when I go yeah like I'm you
know like um yeah this place makes me
feel a little bit more right sighs yeah
but it's not sometimes it's bad
sometimes it's good yeah there's both
are you both yeah yeah I think that
sometimes I got drove past Tiffany Lanes
bowling alley yesterday on highway 190
and I lost my virginity back there you
know yeah who's the young lady um woman
it was a girl
it was it how old yeah we were both
children and that's legal how old were
Hannah I was probably 17 and people are
throwing rocks at us the whole time
we're [ __ ] what yeah Middle Eastern I
don't know why but if you never saw a
[ __ ] duck but a [ __ ] hot and yeah
but whatever it takes a bus whatever it
takes
she took me she took a piece of shale to
the neck that I thought that Louisiana
she's like is that a hickey
that might be a limestone Hickey with a
professed powered through it I had to
man I was young and all I wanted to do
was [ __ ] man at that point it's I feel
like semen is just hiding under your
skin ready to get out anyway you have to
get it out like yeah you break your arm
and just come all over the yes you know
like any like anything somebody sneeze
you'd have a [ __ ] isquite over your
[ __ ] cousin yes in your face but so
they're just own rocks are you a jock
people were excited you know and that's
how they celebrate some of these kids
come on buddy
he always said get in there no matter
what you were doing dude in there they
could be like dropping somebody at a
funeral in town into the grave and he
would always say that and he would
recite some like ac/dc lyrics every now
and then he had a mental and he had a
mental condition yeah and uh and so that
boy would go off and he was there for
when you lost your virginity well he was
yeah people always bring him in the [ __ ]
be like oh let's get get in there they
called him get in there yeah if I put
him in the back you know so they'd be
basketball games is great you know get
it you know I'm not trying to sex though
yeah when you trying to [ __ ] you know
and hide from a [ __ ] shale storm you
know not these disdain age there's no
one who has like this as grown man has
catchphrases but when you're a kid there
was yeah when you were kids or was
catchphrases they used to do this thing
in my neighborhood be like 'i'm mad that
people ever do that but you know what if
you were mad right say if you were upset
about so yeah people could tell you're
upset they would be like this um and
they would hit their throat with their
oh no definitely not there's something
about it it makes you so much matter so
when you're like I said they go yo you
mad
well right up in your face of like iam
mad it makes you so much matter that
you're mine I love that yeah like that
make me laugh not when you're kidding
you're mad you're kidding you're mad
dude and somebody's like yeah man
oh I can throw it burnt it's like
somebody taking the top of your spine
and just starting it's the holiday feel
like it'd be cool with that did you use
protection when this young lady no no
there was a time period unlike where
people use protection
I don't really gets going away more
going away I feel like if you had an STD
you're not doing [ __ ] yeah I mean I
remember what they don't even have any
STDs anymore I don't think you can get
there's pills these days though pills
and shots yeah yeah I know they got him
the side besides the AIDS yeah you know
who's got AIDS now only but sex and who
even has I mean some people are trying
to have butt sex I think you know people
always be trying to do that but who I
can't there was a girl that I think had
AIDS and that's the last person I
remember and you still hooked up with
her no no I never nine it I didn't know
where I knew her through a friend
because now if you have AIDS it's all
like you're your cool do you take a
cocktail every week and it's straight
it's almost like somebody who has AIDS
is probably a little more organizing
somebody who doesn't gotta be on that
pill regimen it see it's it's like
diabetes yeah I was almost excited when
they told me I might have it you had it
[ __ ] Stage one damn I have a sugar boy
sugar boy in the kid sugar sweet teeth
sweet teeth yeah you got that sweet tea
down in Louisiana I love that [ __ ] oh
dude they'll hide that sugar in your ass
bro yeah
when I was young if you wouldn't eat
sugar they put a [ __ ] cube right yeah
so make sense there's different times
and suppositories used to be big
remember that yeah I remember just a
buddy moneys to put whiskey up his
[ __ ] oh yeah you get [ __ ] up cuz
just past your liver goes straight to
your brain you know I'm saying thank you
dude what do you mean how you take you
it's nice to dr. King here a train
conductor bro you look like a [ __ ]
straight-up shrink and all aboard the
truck all aboard the chin to what we're
talking about oh how you put alcohol on
your booty oh yeah it's easy man you get
like one of those things they put oil in
the truck really cuz your [ __ ]
yeah like a like oh my buddy used to do
that all the time but that's like you
got to hold that thing like a martini
glass when you go it's disgusting for
sure and you need some help no he's not
yeah he's actually running drugs for the
cartel he's in hiding now but anyways
and you out you'd also sniff alcohol too
oh really yeah you get [ __ ] head but
people yeah dad I could see yeah I could
see people sniffing alcohol they had a
man speaking of alcohol and head button
they had a black man that um that one
time we go get like tock Avadh keys to
be the kind of vodka that we would drink
it was just like this off-brand in our
region like Todd's almost uh yeah
probably like something like that just
like whatever every place had their own
little local brand or whatever this this
was called taka and so you go get a
fifth of talk or whatever so one time I
pull up by the gas station and they had
this man not singing out this guy'll by
some Bach he looks like he drinks and
vodka and it was daytime you know it
probably maybe 11 a.m. so I I pick it I
say hey man will you get us some liquor
he said yeah said all right here's the
money you got to go in and get the
liquor come back out and get in the car
it's kind of dude yet to give exact
directions to yeah otherwise getting
deviate from the plan I buy like some
[ __ ] slim jims and a scratch-off yes
[ __ ] the dice yeah so anyway he gets
back in the car he's got the liquor and
that's when this dude told me he's like
you know I'm the head button champion in
the world right last thing you want to
hear from I'm talking this guy the only
man I've ever seen yeah he had that
thick head oh this guy's head was
probably made by that shoemaker right he
had that kind of head yet smaller than
chin said chin has a dome one it was
like Chin's head with another yeah it
was that jaundice snowman was like
stacking up a couple of jinns heads
right this guy had just like you could
see his NIT you could hear his neck if
you put your ear up to his neck he
couldn't his neck oh man I'm tired
you know have you had said button people
no he goes I'm driving us off he has a
vodka and all my I want the vodka from
him I trying to get [ __ ] up and he
goes you know I'm the head button
champion of the world right and this
dude's homeless ok2say
I don't know there's cancer and this
before they had it this way before this
is 20 years before Kimbo Slice right
yeah and this man look exactly like
Kimbo Slice right but white with a
two-story hit white or black alright
100% black and he so next thing you know
you guys you know in the hit button
chamber in the world and you start to
see him kind of just looking at me as I
just feel like suddenly size them up you
don't ya suddenly I'm looking forward
driving and he's looking directly at me
right feel there is no us we're not
going anywhere anymore he is just in the
car with me and uh and so I pull any
goes you want he goes do you think you
could beat me and I knew but when he
said do you think anything at that point
I'm already some thinking about funeral
I'm thinking a back but you can't just
get out of a car when you're driving and
that's one of the issues with cars is
that you ever some responsibility to
stay in there at least it's yours so I
stopped pull over cuz I'm not gonna get
knocked unconscious while I'm moving
forward you know what I'm saying about a
[ __ ] idiot
yeah so this dude he goes you want to
know and he couldn't even hear me
anymore than I'm saying no you see in
red oh yeah for him it's game time
yeah I'm saying no in different ways and
saying no in different languages and you
can tell it's not registering in his
head and he just lines me up right and
just hit me as hard as he go with his
[ __ ] head yeah not me completely
unconscious won't even knocked out twice
in my life once was actually about three
weeks ago when I fell under the snow for
when I was resting with some children
the other time was when this dude the
self-proclaimed head button champion of
the world
[ __ ] put that one hit sleeper on me
bro here's the crazy part he didn't
touch him with his hands everything was
gone dude everything was going home with
me
the chant though that's the chair we can
say yeah not dumped out of jail it's a
kind of an honor man my first thought
was did that Duty's the chair and my
first thought that's the champ right
there hey kid bring up head-butting
champ of the world
he's like be on their plate I think it's
a real competition hey have you ever
seen that the slapping contest oh yeah
we used to do that put sugar in each
other's mouths and try to slap it out
really yeah this guy epic head pudding
Cup
that guy looks like a rapist honestly
yeah a little bit of the world all right
let's see it and I'm guessing off a JPEG
right there oh here's the solid for
head-on oh yeah guys does this show put
up this ticker and does this like some
[ __ ] Brian would do but like literally
training rounds like yeah ah my family's
from Zimbabwe
I am very short tongue because we used
to eat berries off the vine not a good
impersonation really oh here's a guy
head-butting an animal a bichon
hopefully is that a Bichon what's a
beast
dude this video hall looks absolutely
amazing this one it's a helmet on let's
it go oh you bet [ __ ] up I don't oh
that's kind of [ __ ] up to do the go Oh
goats [ __ ] them up oh this oh damn is
in Louisiana
oh they're auditioning for something
[ __ ] trying to make ridiculous
all winner gets to [ __ ] somebody at the
house I've been thing that's awesome
though animal Oh
wowthat's guy looks pretty funny mom so
I'm about to get a headache thank you
mom thank you go back to and go to the
WorldStarHipHop headbutt Cup compilation
right there
and this man oh yeah you know I was good
had a solid head but you [ __ ] your world
took me out god I wish it was really
good not though they didn't have video
back then there was a drawing of it I
think I told my buddy you need drew a
picture of it somebody but something you
should legalize headbutts in the UFC
what if this is a fake video
oh they're illegal hell yeah they're
illegal this is the worst fighting or
[ __ ] [ __ ] on their hands that
person's wearing it's not a
WorldStarHipHop what pants would you
fight in if you had to fight dude in
pants yeah oh really do you like these
he's a little stretchy but they cover
everything I need to cover but they're
not too baggy either you know if I can
work if you were in yeah and they're
tight in the ankle you know that's what
I want oh yeah I'm so stupid this is so
Russian yeah this is some Russian [ __ ]
the slapping competition though I
thinking how people don't get most of
them do they just get knocked the [ __ ]
out to tough for their own good you've
been slapped really hard mmm I think let
me think what happened a girl slapped
with her yeah slap you guys I feel like
it's more embarrassing than a punch I
really push on a slap
there's dude named Wade slapped me one
time fat Wade was very wide Wade slap
you you know he just didn't have much to
say and he was angry for years and it
finally came out in a big slap and his
daddy drove the school bus his dad was a
Milford and his dad drove the school bus
and he was Irish
I guess he was Irish I don't know he
never really said anything
Wade and Milford don't sound very Irish
that's true good point yeah so they
might not have been Irish dude but they
looked really Irish had a lot of Irish
characteristics for not being from there
and they are a meal for drove the bus
dude you know a short bus regular dude
well and I never rode short actually one
time I rode sure
but just to talk to the driver was
hottest [ __ ] me dude we had the finest
short bus driver in our pretended you
were kind of slow just to get on the
short bus oh dude I get on there
one of my buddies right he thought he
was trying to be handicapped on there he
tied his legs together right and made
like a long like Forrest Gump style yeah
and he caught a pretend he had one leg
like dude that's how you Britain you up
one leg like you tie one leg behind you
or something just like he had two legs
tied together he probably works issues
like this dumbass yeah go ahead and get
on the bus get in the back she's
probably like I bet this boy's got a
dick on him you know cuz I would think
that if I saw somebody with one big-ass
thick leg boy you'd have a fat dick to
the front they have to be they say that
people that are 511 at big dicks that's
what I've heard some girl told me that
why 511 she just said if you're 511 or
shorter or like five nine to five eleven
you have like a fat dick syndrome fat
and short yeah like you ever seen that
that documentary on HBO it's called like
night women or something like that's on
prostitutes and they mic this one
prostitute up it's my favorite scene
ever in the documentary because they
might grow up and sheets in a car with a
John and he she goes I baby get it out
and they're like negotiating the price
shoes alright baby get out and they just
hear your silence and then hear slurping
there here you go ooh you got that you
got that short fat you get that short
fat dick
my favorite scene ever now why Dixie
heater man I came in wide broad when I
was young and I remember it takes almost
all the blood out of your body can't
think that well when you get an erection
I got like like one of those short coke
cans you know they give the kids not
short short and fat is yours a full coke
can now or yeah I mean I got it I mean
it's yeah but I'm more like I'm
definitely more of a width and a length
guy you know what I'm saying like you
see my dick you're like oh I put a watch
on that you know oh weird but you don't
see me like oh you know that thing
be a ruler yeah yeah I got that young
attack artist brother I got that chubby
in the [ __ ] you know I got Napoleon's
kind of taller chubby brother but still
holy dick now yet the job dig the chubby
my dick couldn't really wear a
turtleneck cuz it doesn't really have a
neck it's just all oh yeah basically the
cankles of dick a solid ankle the hand
bro
it's almost angled it's like Jarrod
Lorenzen they used to play verka
university Kentucky quarterback lick of
the charts that's like what seasons like
we just can't anymore that [ __ ]
for Kentucky had a cannon have you seen
him lately something local oblique there
he is not that right there yeah throwing
a waffle into his cousin's mouth right
there above [ __ ] is huge ain't good
slang that there is in college in gay
there he is right there in college he
was an animal you solid for sure but
yeah man that put that man put me
unconscious do you have on champ he was
a champ and I never saw him again and he
took that liquor and that was it
hopefully you know hopefully just
probably stop I've guarantees it's dead
for sure
this boy's close to dying - he's 500
pounds oh wow
there is right there trying to rip into
a bag of chips with that picture on the
right you know what I assume he has a
cankle dick as well you know what's
funny is that's hilarious to me that he
came to a show one time and brought me a
shirt when I performed in Lexington oh
really yeah and it says straight out of
Lexington on it's pretty cool he's a
nice guy yeah super nice but yeah I mean
he makes fun of himself all the time I
mean he's well this nobody was built
like him
I play quarterback ever yeah you playing
a left tackle playing quarterback
yeah people I can't play marbles or play
Dungeons & Dragons well yeah this boy
would stand at the the mentally
handicapped kid in our neighborhood he
live down at the end of the street he
would just do ac/dc lyrics you know and
you just over and over yeah he just
you'd be on his porch like this I'm not
bad though I'd rather I'd prefer that
than him like rocking out some [ __ ]
viii oh he was heavy you can put a
minute that's the thing about sometimes
if somebody gets hooked on something in
their head and they have something a
good song lyric you can at least take
him to some concerts put him in the back
hell yeah enjoy that ride what's less
constant you went through oh it was um
you big concert guys I'm not very much
man either my buddy James Blake I went
saw my buddy James Blake he's a British
musician and he was his famous song he
had a banger for a second there
obviously super slow I haven't listened
to a honestly sadly haven't listened to
a ton of his music but he this one song
that was just a banger but he's such an
he's just such an easy to neat managin
just a neat artist and I met him through
a friend of mine who's an actress and
and I went to his concert at a church
and it was cool man he like I never
listen to this type of music I never
listen to this type of musing it get
slightly slower it's like this was used
to for me to it's a science it's like
almost watching that brilliant man yeah
I never listened to much music you know
something's wrong with me two months ago
1 million views oh that's a car that oh
that that's a good tune what's something
that I listen to
he hasn't got your grade it that sounds
familiar to me how about what has the
most retro Gators is a song I've ever
seen doing over there you know right
David Wow
would you meet this man there his
girlfriend but this is the last concert
that our that you went through where was
the vet it was in Los Angeles yeah yeah
it's like listening to him it's like
listen like uh it's like a lab tech in a
church kind of sometimes he's just like
this I don't know I've never heard this
type of music who'll do too huh yeah
he's an e yeah he's an eater yeah I
didn't I didn't know his music I knew
him before I knew his music hmm I only
know one of his songs why not I'm not
sure you know banger this is slow video
though
yeah he just got that thing make you I
mean look we call that panty-dropper oh
that dude look I'm not a fan of uh you
know I don't subscribe to what to call
you have sex with someone that you're
related to Oh incest you're not a fan of
incest you know no Betty in these times
hardpack but lo I would more paths
I wouldn't put this on at the house
around one of my hot cousins either I'll
tell you that yeah I would either do
this late at night the power goes out
but you have a generator that's just
connected to the radio and you got this
going somebody's gonna wake oh they're
[ __ ]
yes oh he's waking up different we call
awaken of difference yeah I'll do it
yeah this is me I forget which one is
bang you though you know chin fancied
himself a musician oh god Brooke
marijuana
yeah head of my brothers one of the best
put a video on the Instagram of him and
Chin's been instrumental in helping Alex
getting a podcast going you guys old
studio yeah you know the ghost of chintz
must past is in there sometimes it's
just you and then your old your old
producer it's just me right now we're
trying to get it you know get a producer
in we just had Jay Mohr and as a guest
how was Jay I mean that guy is stories
for days Oh stories for days man he
talked about they paid or him and Dave
Attell got Chris Farley to [ __ ] out of a
window one time when they all what a
brilliant I mean he has stories for days
right it's unbelievable and he has it
impersonations it's almost like being
he's so talented so talented so I people
forget how how brilliant yeah I mean if
you saw some of his old comedy I'm you
talking some of his sets you know the
one of the greats men when someone says
oh he's young one of the greats he's
he's afflicted he's infected with talent
it's almost an infection I feel like
with some people like him
yeah you know like Robin Williams I
think was a guy that had it you know
correct um Chris Farley you know there
really are troubled artists yeah and
they don't have as many of those any you
know a lot of times I feel like
Hollywood sells you a lot of these you
know joke writers and hey come watch
this person do comedy and it's like oh I
could watch that there's there's nothing
about that person
and special yeah that's not tracking - -
no I don't care about no it's not unique
right but I think some of that starting
to change you know and I think you're
starting to get people that are actually
more personalities that people want to
see and just want to go and spend time
with yeah you know like I go watch the
basket Maniscalco to spend time with
Brian Collins another guy yes like I
don't care I could see how could hear
Brian tell the same thing to me a
thousand times you just want to see I
want to see him do it Sebastian the same
way I think you're the same way I think
you're you're the your when the guys
where it's unique or you can't get it
anywhere else
yeah like when we're talking about
people where I'll see some something on
Netflix or you know whatever Amazon or
you - I'm like I can see how they got
there I've seen that oh yeah I've seen
that perspective yeah I wouldn't pay to
see that again yeah I wouldn't pay to
see it again yeah well thanks man I
appreciate ya I like doing the job man
have you have you adapted man you've
really gone - hook line & sinker in
trying to working on it Ryan brothers
admirable yeah thanks man it's hard dude
because I mean I'm sure there were times
and you're like [ __ ] do I don't need to
drive over there and do this comedy
tonight or do I need to drive over there
in practice or do this set yeah it's
stressful what's getting easier about it
is anything getting easier or is it uh
the thing that stresses well the the I
feel like and I literally just met with
my team last week about this my team is
a team listen this guy there when you
were his team can I get stressed that
it's not like it's never ending you know
I'm saying like as far as comedy goes in
writing it's just if you were if like
and there's some comics do this but if
you wanted to you could literally focus
on something every single day and come
up something new trying to come
something new every single day yeah it's
like a painting you're literally never
gonna finish yeah work on it 24 hours a
day it's never get it done and that's
that stresses me yeah I have a hard time
dealing with that
why because oh because you can see like
it just there's immense others immense
things you could keep they're like I'm
so behind the wheel like like I have to
like with the show time thing I love
doing it's great but then it takes away
from over here
yeah I'm saying so I don't know yeah
that's why we explain it's hard to
explain I could see
man yeah it seems like yeah I could I
could see that you start building things
and having different ideas you're like
okay well let's try to implement this
idea and get this going you know you
know and Chin's in here working you said
it work 27 hours the other day I'm like
well it's impossible you know well
someone's left my ass up you take calls
on your podcast yeah we take calls man
we take calls from people a lot of
people out there struggling with stuff
jerk and all man called me yesterday not
joking was in his truck man like I'm
about to jerk off right now and I don't
want to why I don't know that truck
somewhere did you encourage that man to
Jack escape it I'm trying to escape
pornography man I spend like a decade
jerking off at the house man you do your
sex addict do you believe that when you
guys say their sex addict I think some
people are yeah I think I don't know if
and I don't know if it's sex anymore I
don't know what got us so faith in my
baby know maybe it is I'm just trying to
think it is it the chase is when I hear
guys go I'm a sex addict it depends it
depends where they're at and I think it
depends with that and it depends what
access they have the woman yeah that
makes sense when your sex addict I'm
like well you could just be
undisciplined right if you have a if
you're married and you're you're famous
in whatever lane you're in and you go on
the road or you're doing strike you know
you do it so you're gonna have all this
all this temptation thrown your way
what's the end but whole lot of dudes be
throwing bus and if that's your flavor
more more power to suck that dick look
that ass
however it's is it a are you addicted
you son discipline right there's a big
difference yeah yeah there is man it's
tough you know some guys you know like I
think you know some guys there and some
guys are better at it some guys are just
so hooked on it I think that becomes an
addiction though you know well my
problem is if well not my problem but
some guys I know who have problems with
it who are in the limelight
it distracts them from doing their
actual work oh yeah it's like instead of
you could be home riding and you'd be
home doing this you could be doing more
stand-up or you could be doing this
podcast or this TV show but instead
you're chasing [ __ ] yeah so you put all
your energy into that yeah next thing
you know you you you
no next thing you know you got a you
know you you know you got a black belt
in chasing [ __ ] but that doesn't pay
the bill yeah stop paying the bills and
they're all you're on stage and people
are like what do you you know what's
your next bid and you're just showing
them you know nothing create I mean I
guess if you're singing LICO some good
bits and experiences from chasing girls
but if you're a grown-ass man it's me
tough it gets limited you can't be like
oh yeah whatever this girl's house and
you know we both had to brush our teeth
before you like it doesn't get cool as
you get older they'll know it's sad yeah
we'd had a big dinner so nobody was [ __ ]
your mid mid forties you talking about
[ __ ] girls on stage saying alright
man well yeah row sex is I think sex is
for children man you know sober sex is
for children if you're [ __ ] sober and
you're an adult dude you are I think you
might be going to hell like that
sober sex is for kids dude you prefer to
be drugged up I think yeah as an adult
you've done on nyquil
don't give me any idea covering I don't
know if I can't or not I found them
recovery if I could take nyquil I don't
think so man I mean I could have a sip
if I have two sips see that's how he
goes I'll have a sip next we know your
[ __ ] fault even nyquil every night a
day you know you're sprinkling it in
your head behind it like somebody
brought that boy to a funeral I remember
the only rule was do not say it and he
was quiet the whole time so they lowered
that casket their own chair or like get
the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] if you were
just like celebrate it
how's your house your meetings going
with the with the a or I don't know yeah
talk about it sometimes a man it's like
I find it fascinating cuz I'm not part
of it I've never been addicted really to
I had a slight addiction to painkillers
but when people have like serious issues
I'm fascinated by yeah yeah yeah I think
well most of my most of my field
fascinating most of my addiction I've
found over time is that I was just I was
uncomfortable being myself comfortable
yeah like I would just be anywhere I
would be I would just be uncomfortable
so you'd medicate that and so at some
point I found you know I would just
somehow I started doing some cocaine
here and there and it wasn't anything
create a nose for cocaine oh yeah I'll
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] kill the neighbors
gram if they leave their window I got
that snout now these now I'll kilogram a
cinnamon from an aisle over brother
you know I'll [ __ ] put a spice rack on
its knees but cocaine was the drug of
choice we here's what happened cocaine
started to be kind of like it's like a
sneaky drug and it had some mystery you
know people sneaking around you know
people are like hands in it under the
table and stuff yeah just said like you
know I don't where ever anywhere you are
open party now it's a little more open
but it's still like you know if you're
at the bank or something somebody has a
gram they're not gonna set it on the
counter Taylor the chase bharosa chasing
that high voice but so there was a
little bit of mystery to it you sneak
off and do it there was a little bit of
like that and I like that I like the
mystery almost like the the sneaky
criminal aspect of it yeah there was
some criminal about to get a show but
somebody's place you didn't know you'd I
used to meet a dude who would bring on
he had a wolf this guy had a wolf a pet
wolf
I don't was a pad I mean they knew each
other who takes some drugs though
roommates roommates at least yeah
friends yeah at least and this dude
somebody gave me his number one time and
years later I'm texting this guy and he
met me somewhere and he you know it was
bummed out that is you know he's selling
cocaine you got this wolf well and you
look you think you won't you won't try
anything on to do with the wolf dude
with a bichon I guess some guys run up
with a Schnauzer you know saying or a
little bit of a you know a yellow Bowser
or whatever those dogs are Yulin
whatever drugs he has he show up with a
bang hey you show up with a wiener dog
I'm gonna fake and take you to jail
somebody's getting [ __ ] choked out
and I'm stealing this pup yeah they're
friendly as fire and the wet noses
but I won't let a wet nose near my
cocaine now then what that's why they
probably have those walls because they
have them dry sniffs yeah can't have no
nails without wet ass nose around them
drugs yeah you got that dry front so
wolf got that dry intake so they you
know but this man pulled a [ __ ] wolf
up this dude that this him probably
weighed 62 63 pounds I cement pulls up
with this wolf the second time I went in
saw this man he's late he's running late
and his much something happened his
mother had passed away do not the
student just found out about her what so
now this dude is crying bro this man I
don't know sit in the back of my car
crying hey just give me with dog in
there in the car man and I'm so scared
and like I don't even know this dude
wolf is price said the wolf says out the
window like and so then other people
start to come in the distance people
hear a wolf it's la oh yeah people think
it needs to be rescued you know it's
like no this Wolf's just trying to
[ __ ] sell a gram you know of selling
grams thud but so there was part of that
there was always some mystique with it
and I don't and I honestly I don't even
know how big of a I wasn't doing drugs
forever you ever do something strange
for some change no I never did anything
like that one man taught me to do
something one time in New Orleans but I
had to go to the airport well yeah I
don't know bro so he's doing some code
you could just feel somebody's dick
about to come out in the room yeah that
you couldn't refuse
yeah yeah I was in a bathroom that had
locks on both sides of the door so
that's when I knew it was squirrely but
thank God I had to catch that flight you
know but yeah so that was but anyway I
started going to I started going to some
of these means and then when did you
know it was time to go to these meetings
what was rock bottom cuz like if you
watch intervention the the therapist
always says they have to hit rock bottom
otherwise you can keep doing them yeah
yeah and I didn't have anything like I
wasn't the guy nothing crazy was
happening for me I was I drove one time
I drove a car and this is a YouTube clip
that just came out I drove a car I was
high on cocaine driving a taxi in New
York and Daryl and I'm ended up meeting
Darryl Strawberry well
some drugs no he was 13 years sober and
this was on it was just on that this is
not happening
that Ari Shaffir news well not a new
she's not artist Rafi yeah they took her
home all how dare you yeah they took it
from mother took you promoted but yeah
so so anyhow I was all that story I told
that story really and it's a true story
man always ended up I was partying with
this cocaine with this taxi driver and
you know he bought me an escort I didn't
want any escort and I just you know is
the nicest taxi driver of all time Isis
a little bunju Luigi bought you an
escort Oh was she fine with my own money
but still you know he hooked it up he
hooked it up and then and then and drugs
I'll pay for the drug steal but still he
hooked it up it's just one stop shops
but it's connected yeah and he picked up
Darryl Strawberry no and then we end up
on the O pian ah Jim Norton radio show
oh yeah I loved you I could even talk
and the other guest for the day was mr.
Darryl Strawberry and that was when
there was this weird moment for me like
here was a good opportunity for me being
on with Opie and Jim you know two men
that I'm higher yeah Hugh Jill and Jim
Norton of the funniest men alive I think
agree and and I couldn't even talk cuz
you're so high yeah and I'd left a pod
left a party at 1:00 a.m. that the night
before to get home just to go home and
be ready for this moment this taxi
driver trying to party and this will and
something that yeah there was a couple
elements where next thing you know there
and so it just made me think like man
like you're not a hundred percent in
control of what you're doing all the
time yeah and I didn't want to be there
and so then I started going to these
meetings and then some things changed
for me I used to think that the world
was always against me
you know I grew up in this poor white
environment and like you know not a lot
has done from my perspective for poor
white people everybody thinks they're
racist everybody things sit there you
know your poor black your poor Latino
there's all kinds of for there's a lot
of programs there's a lot more outreach
yeah and there's a lot more from the
media as if that's okay yeah but you're
poor and white it's like you did
something wrong you've been lost you
know yeah I didn't do anything wrong you
know my father's from Nicaragua my
mother's from Illinois like I was just
alive that's all I did yeah and so I
grew up with this chip on my shoulder
and I always thought the whole world was
against me which is why you're
successful coach I think it served me
well but it got to a point where was I
serving me well it doesn't walk
doesn't feel good at a certain age
walking around feeling like that all the
time yeah and the AAA program for me has
helped me to realize that that's not the
truth that's just the truth that I was
carrying that's the truth that you came
up with yourself right to get well it's
almost like you came up with yourself to
get out of those conditions right to
survive I needed it yeah I needed some
chip on my shoulder and then but then at
this point in my career wasn't serving
me well anymore
and so that program helped me to realize
that the whole world wasn't against me
by just talking about it by taking you
through this 12 steps I got 12 steps in
there and I'm not even through all of
them but just see it in there but step
you on almost step for God take me a
long ways to go
yeah man it's a steep case bro God yes
it's journey it's a journey you still
feel it you feel good about yourself
yeah oh good I feel better I feel like I
have a better shot at just being living
a more comfortable future for my insides
it's the thing was even about like I
don't care about drinking or drugs but I
do care about how I feel inside of
myself but I think as a comic and a lot
of kid comics say the same thing I don't
think there's any comment it's a fine
line between knowing you're good at what
you do but also hate your work yeah you
don't wanna be like on the best-ever I'm
the greatest comic in the world yeah you
know because I don't think that that
brings any sort of creativity - yeah a
lot of ego
yeah I think I think you have to an ego
go I can do this and I'm fearless at the
same time that I think my material sucks
yeah
yeah I think always when you look back
at your old material it's gonna suck
dick dude - I'm sure we go chimp late
his first song if you look back at some
of that what were you playing it's
actually pretty good in just kitchens
always busy but I can see it I don't
know I bet he's effective yeah I've
known him for like three years I've no
idea it's a Ford he might be terrible in
his 20 but even with on this is not
happening I'm on the next season season
five huh
I'm on season five we and how long would
you do we do we shoot that six months
ago at least for me probably long enough
oh yeah they're doing two seasons I was
doing the next time on the next one Wow
put the story that they have I've taken
that and I've evolved into a full
thirty-minute set yeah that's part of my
act I
toss I almost don't want to hear it I
know I'm like no no no hold up I don't
know I need that no no no hear that
that's a [ __ ] and then they added on
my teddy it's 10 minutes the [ __ ] oh
don't do that yeah you know it's a
four-minute yeah my agents like no it's
Comedy Central like mmm son yeah I'd
rather air our own stuff these days and
do Comedy Central man you know no
disrespect but only they only pay me
they paid they paid me $1,500 for this
everyone its routine yeah and it's from
one evening it's different I'm in a
different Lane than you are right for me
just do stand-up all I would have paid
to do it you know I need to be on
economy sense that's a good point a guy
like me and my biggest issues I'm almost
embarrassed if you go you're a comic and
like you know like I'm like I'm
embarrassed of it but that's got my own
issues that's kind of funny yeah it when
is their own issues that should be your
special called embarrassed embarrassed
yeah like god I'm embarrassed to be
doing this but you just don't keep doing
it well I love it's my you know it's
right kid I want to do it but yeah it's
it's I feel like I haven't paid my dues
refer to myself as a comic yeah like
when I'm around other comics I feel like
the punter on the football team do you
oh yeah I got it like I didn't I didn't
pay my dues I didn't I wasn't I wasn't
in the gym while everyone else oh shoot
yeah right no right there so you're at
North to change into folk trick where
were you in footed we were shooting in
the gym you like did I that's like
getting punched in the face when I put a
new carburetor into a sale rack no baby
but yeah man I appreciate you know I
mean this yeah I don't know have to have
felt more comfortable since I since I
started going to that program for me and
that's huge right yeah it is for me it's
it's been it's been helpful man it's
been helpful and I don't know if I'll
always be in it I don't know if I'll
always feel that way how long you been
at almost two years in July and you'd
only have four yeah yeah yeah a long way
to go son yeah Justin so I do want to
get through the steps and you know and
then I have other people that reach out
on them like man I'm in the pro you know
I'll do this or I'll struggle with some
of this and so then I feel a little bit
like you know it inspires me because
it's like oh well you know I can go one
more day out here somebody's crazy story
yeah I know and that's what the meetings
are for you go to these
meetings and somebody tells you the
craziest story it's inspiring it's
inspiring like I can do this one where
they forget them yeah yeah well they
have and I'm sure it's in current events
we see like the rock was like I suffered
with depression as a kid and you know I
cry every day or my mom strike him in
suicide out of stuff I was thinking
about and Peter like damn the rock seems
like the happ's guy ever and I think
there's a difference between clinical
depression yeah I'm being depressed at a
part of your life right as I've had
times during my fight career football
career life in general I'm depressed
yeah I don't need I don't need
medication difference between having a
brain where you're clinically depressed
and then going through moments in life
where you're depressed I think we make
it we need to kind of draw the line
there cuz everyone goes down I know the
rock had mental issues mmm I think he's
going through a rough patch in his life
yeah I don't think he's clinically
depressed like everyone else yeah I mean
he named itself after a piece of gravel
right but that'll make him a bad guy
right we've all rough time rough times
but no I feel you and I think a lot of
these and especially dude is so funny I
was gonna say Yahoo Yahoo I feeI used to
love you always to work for them really
become this company where it's like
every day it's like this celebrity had
an eating disorder as a child it's like
they just use things to try and make
celebrities seem [ __ ] up [ __ ] up to
make them seem more likable to fans and
here's the problem with that and most
people and even even I was a victim of
this where I thought as a comic man I'm
not as [ __ ] up in darkness all comics
are and Brian goes hold on all comics
aren't like that
yeah a reason you think that is because
they glorify that there's a lot of
comics who are just fine right but you
see in music you see in acting you see
in sports the guys who are [ __ ] up it
gets broadcast the world now so you
assume everyone's like that and that's
not true
oh it's interesting and the odds would
even say out of musicians actors artists
--is comics when artists iziz of artists
like artists comics oh yeah you got
brain trauma
yeah yeah see I didn't get clear the
down syndrome like you but I got my own
issues my bad man I feel so bad yeah but
they're saying after like got you hand
they're saying if you look at the odds
the odds are most those people do not
have it we just glorified the ones that
do yeah yeah damn your [ __ ] brain
trauma yeah man I'm sitting here this
whole time acting like you didn't
comment on me my bad no no no but I've
made fun of you because you had Down
syndrome
yeah how might be worse you got cleared
of it it depends man you know you got to
get in there beat it bro you gonna shift
your own gene sometimes I feel I'm
trying to shift these genes but no it
look man I do think it's like so what
happens when we get to the point where
we have used everything even things that
are really serious and like the like
because I feel like it's like the news
and and the media that may it's like oh
we need this star to seem more likable
to sell books next year next month it's
like now let's make them have an eating
just you know not make them or or or
let's glorify it even if it wasn't that
bad oh you had you struggled this or in
high school you actually liked another
dude
right well you're gender-neutral yeah
yeah let's do that yes why the flag hums
like God dawg yeah yeah yeah that's kind
of gay are you trying to get some fans
in this area where it what it does its
same thing with like these this me to
movement where someone to come up like
oh I had this issue where was it an
issue it's consensual you're actually
down have done this as many of dudes
what you're doing is you're [ __ ] up
the movement because there's some actual
victims right and now when you do that
that you get the spotlight it takes away
from the actual victim yeah like
Jennifer Lawrence came out had some
story it was just like you know some guy
you know looked at me like while I was
changing a clothing or something I'm
just like what I thought so many celebs
photos will jump on you know and that
kind of stuff we just want to relate to
it yeah they just want to relate and
they don't want to miss out on the
opportunity to seem correct it had their
name in the news you know but I think a
lot of America's starting to get hip to
that kind of stuff these days some of it
yeah and they're I think they're sick of
it yeah I mean I think you saw that with
like the Academy Awards it's like it was
like their lowest percentage watched
ever or the biggest drop you know
someone said to drop like 17% of viewers
yeah I have to work that I was bored oh
yeah I was I was working the red carpet
for yeah I was born yeah yeah yeah and I
think and I
mark my words um who who's the man
that's the country man that's on the
east today Miranda Lambert you remember
that man shelter Lake Shelton I bet he
has so many offers coming into him right
he will host one of those award shows
next year everybody's gonna look like
who's the only person we know that can
like relate to half of America blade
shown oh I think he's gonna be
Hollywood's first thought why because
they look at their networks like we had
well they haven't had a talking like
southern or rural kind of vibe like they
haven't had a southern person on a
sitcom this would kind of hurt to my
feelings when I get out here they like
come out here and live your dream they
haven't had a southern person on a
sitcom a person with a rural accent I
can't even think a win well they have My
Name Is Earl but we will but like on a
main Network sitcom but also like the
whole redneck movement you might be a
redneck if yeah that was 25 years ago
that came out that huge he had his own
show - yeah he has on the show but since
then it's like those people are banned
from like TV and I'm not even a redneck
I'm just grew up in a [ __ ] [ __ ]
area yeah you know you couldn't have a
bass boat wouldn't have NASCAR you know
I'm saying we didn't have but maybe at
Willie Nelson I'll play Willie Nelson
but isn't rednecks is the equivalent of
you know like get up for if you refer to
anyone who's poor as ghetto wouldn't
white people ghetto be redneck yeah are
ghetto version yeah I guess so we're
white trash I like white trash a lot
better I can relate to that
then redneck yeah they just think like
well yeah redneck they just know about
poor South like yeah yeah redneck seems
like it's more of a brand to me yeah the
word you don't have to be poor like you
can still be redneck can have your [ __ ]
together right the meaning maybe your
dad worked at Home Depot and you drive a
truck with them steel nuts in the back
yeah it's lifted and you kind of your
[ __ ] together we have a mullet fight you
know you were a tank tops and shitty tan
and you drink [ __ ] Bud Light yeah I
go to the lake with your friend
you're not dead broke and I'm saying
yeah you got it yeah yeah I think that's
it and it's okay I mean all those are
fine but I do feel like sometimes like
the only people you can make fun of an
American anymore like poor white people
and that makes me mad sometimes
you know that's fair it's like oh you
can do any accent you can do any red any
other accent though like it's you know
it's oh that's racist or that's this or
that
you can you know impersonate like a oh
yeah Billy Boy like that it's all good
but then sometimes I'll go to some of
these areas where those people are still
like that and some of those people will
still be like super race it's a super
ignorant and that [ __ ] makes me not feel
sorry for those people you know I mean
like I you know I don't really have a
stomach for you know for just senseless
races no hell these days it's just oh
yeah it's just sad so I'm glad you know
I mean some of the movements and stuff
it's good because some of that stuff
will go away are you trying to be the
voice the the poor white well I'm just I
mean that's all I can be is just where
I'm from that's what you represent yeah
but I am glad that I am yeah I'm sorry
sir you try right the plot of eight
miles you somebody coming in lost like a
bunch of his fans last year he like kind
of went into this rogue your action kind
of really oh I think he's anti-trump
yeah he's anti-trump but it seemed like
he disconnected from some of his base
but I think whatever I just want time
off you think of his hustle yeah you see
this daughter not mad at her really I
would crawl eight miles to get to that
huh yeah I haven't seen it I might crawl
five let me get a picture of it yeah no
you call you most like yes enough are
okay oh damn is that Stan what's her
name Hayley Hayley yeah Hayley oh my god
he looks so much like him bro a little
bit damn I get up in mom's sphaghetti
right there sigh you feel me yeah you
know whatever you say I am real real
Slim Shady stand up Wow but no legs has
she shown any full body pics and what's
up right there yep are you mad at don't
know what so Doug you crawled them eight
miles right damn boy yeah I tell her I
am the jump in that swamp cruiser and
get going oh I'd sneak in her car at a
gas station and tell her I'm the head
button champion of the world
some [ __ ] alligators were here for
him to get to her son
get in there this boy [ __ ] Jarrell
does the dude's name tight Gerald
everybody called him Gerald cuz his
jeans someone's his jeans a little bit
tight not his body not his pants his
genetic genetic genes were yeah some of
them you see people in their little
little tight they fish him for
regularity you know struggle cities what
I call it yeah he struggle city
yeah even struggle city well the bills
about drugs he had good taste in music
nothing wrong how he did man that's what
that's what music was awesome man no
she's not acronym it chin should we do
some current events but I still love him
man I've always been in oh [ __ ] yes yes
GameChanger
yeah he gave everybody purpose
everywhere every poor white kid of his
Eminem as their only purpose you've seen
as facial hair and alright
nobody knows yeah no it looks it's gonna
bum me out let me see word I always
thought he had a little bit honestly and
this isn't it yeah I thought he had an
Asian face odd to me like it just
doesn't fit yeh look suggestion uh don't
say Justin Timberlake just to rates
older daughters like Justin Rose
Timberlake where Justin booty he looks
like the guy that made those boots for
cow it looks like Kevin's Nordic
haberdasher whoever that is he looks
like the guy would feel bad for town and
make him of shitty boots that's really
let's yeah you're like yes thank you i
can clean cut you that's good you you
want him to be the same Eminem Slim
Shady from those you are those TRL days
I just looked on for it just isn't like
compute in my head it doesn't make sense
it looks you know what he looks like he
looks like somebody that's going through
gender relocation yes yeah thank you
that exactly looks like someone who
wishes they were Eminem and he's
confused yeah it looks like somebody
lives they were just a mom to Eminem
yeah that's what it looks like Emma
you're right he looks like he's gonna be
Emma burned Emma
yeah I know you it's like Glee so he's
trying to be over now yeah yeah yeah
it's taking testosterone and the hair
starting to sprout on it definitely and
he looks a little bit Asian doesn't eat
here's kind of an Asian does a little
I think Asians can go in between genders
like like no one else is big yes ties
are
she do you go to Thailand yeah some of
those Thai boys those lady boys nothing
wrong with that if you wake up with a
dick in your mouth in your mouth I mean
your hand
what if y'all just met dig my first met
if he's if he feeds me some sort of
drinks I pass out why would you you
can't do nothing my dead hand you guys
need to go for these lips I'm sorted
drinks are you game who says sorted
drinks watch love you ah this sordid ale
get that hard piss out there thanks bro
yeah I'm sitting over here by my sitting
by this do it anymore
okay three questions right now with
Brendan Schaub three questions alright
you get pulled over by the police right
yeah and you have to hide cocaine or
pills or some very unique rare protein
that you got ahold of like a hemp
protein or like a goats way sure where
do you put it at anus on my ass okay and
how many fingers used to do it honestly
to no more than three oh damn is it
Christmas okay second question everyone
you know is pretty much dying right yeah
and most your family's in a fire okay
who do you go back in to get my son okay
all right Dan those kind of say sorry
but god bless him and god bless your
friends that that passed okay how about
this dude you things don't pan out right
the modeling the yeah yeah the modeling
the wrestling none of it works out right
w either the brown belt or whatever the
new food service you're offering is none
if it works out what job do you end up
getting honestly you have to move back
to Aaron you have to move out the devil
sorry what yeah Denver which is
basically it's the Cleveland of the
mountain
Denver you have to move back to Denver
I'm working on a pen smart Petsmart
that's mine okay I love the animals I
like the blue Paulo they make you wear a
three-credit varnish ow all right let's
get into this news huh yeah let's do
this
did you cover those questions yourself
three questions then but what is sad
about saving my family told us but you
gotta have something there that makes
people you know get to know your
feelings that thing some people's
feelings gonna be hurting I'm not saving
him but you gotta say your son if you
said somebody else to say my girl I knew
this dude son just in there just fending
off flames with a little shield you
bought him or some cheap shield that you
made him oh I once got a shield from
Whitney Cummings said big brown on it
and was a straight-up shield like they
use for the task force oh wow the most
legit shield ever seen my lab she gave
that as a gift yeah did you guys ever
bang her now
[Music]
please hunting baby snatching monkey
after the baby was found dead is this
from my childhood because I uh this is
in Louisiana no India oh yeah like
Little India that's what they call
Louisiana really some parts and we saw
monkeys we didn't hunt monkeys what we
should catch them when I was young
because they got out a monkey in India's
eastern state of Odisha what's this
monkey doing just stealing babies and
killing them it just grabbed a baby
Oh took it slammed it against the wall
and then they found it later it's a
terrible story but I mean it's just
crazy I feel sick okay they should
definitely kill that month so they're
looking for and of course they're gonna
they're trying to find it to kill it
they're looking for that monkey but that
looks like particular monk every monkey
yeah but also let's go ahead and slap
the parents around there's no monkey no
monkey even if I lived in India would be
ever get close to my son but I don't let
strangers at the Grove get close to my
kid
a little the [ __ ] wild mob sit well
this is the angriest I'm hanok I've ever
but these are like people that live in a
villa
you know they can't control that with
they're not like us yeah you couldn't if
you could not defend your child against
monkeys if you wanted to
Sharona would argue this to the end of
the earth
no no no Joe Rogan would argue with
straight up like chimpanzees yeah yeah
we're all [ __ ] yeah
that monkey yeah that's a monkey [ __ ]
slapping the piss out of that thing oh
my god that's a little spider monkey
that is a little spider monkey and look
I'll say this I was in was I in I was in
Malaysia one time doing comedy nope just
just doing being a student I was a
student when I was younger and I was in
Malaysia and I saw a monkey steal a bag
of chips from a black girl right [ __ ]
racist it is racist it's everything you
know it's everything it's stealing food
from people it's Star vez it's
everything
starve it's like artists do you think
you could take you think you just
picture like a healthy black woman you
think you take a bag of chips from her
no and this monkey did it I know but I'm
saying it could do that with a baby yeah
was he on the sneak though was there
always on the sneak over there and just
trying to cap bro they're always on the
seek and they're a sign just say do not
touch the monkeys do not feed the
monkeys don't tell keys don't like us
and that's why we didn't come from
monkeys
he's one of if they're doing this kind
of [ __ ] dude this isn't friendly [ __ ]
you know I know some people would steal
chips - I've seen people steal chips
yeah I've seen human steal chips we come
from monkeys son okay I'll take that
that's a good point I don't think that
we do though I think that they don't
want us here and shits gonna get haywire
soon oh here you go again with the movie
plot so already quoted a smile now you
talking about Planet of the Apes I've
never seen that see ya dude let's go -
okay you want a one more bad one no no
no this is some just crazy one
some people were inside a car with the
loaded gun
the woman said that it's not loaded she
didn't think was loaded the guy next to
her was like dude don't don't point at
me she ends up actually shooting him he
didn't die though but he's in critical
condition so here's this is on Facebook
live to play it is the actual video yeah
but they're not gonna show the actual
thing once
so they're doing a Facebook live thing I
got a left get shot again the Hat what
do you think you got in the Hat
no so there's the gun on that console
are they trying to rob something no
they're just trying to show off and
that's what the girls holding the gun
right now so stupid she said oh she had
annoyed if she thought it was not loaded
so she's trying to show off like she's
hard and the guys he could tell is like
just I'm tearing out like you would
steal her bag of chips can you believe
somebody shot their [ __ ] friend in
her car on Facebook like joke around
quit people should not be just up should
not be allowed to get facebook lock I
agree you have to go through some
requirements also there should be some
requirements for you to start a YouTube
channel - yeah
like she's just doing it for the gram
yeah I'm saying like she's just trying
to get followers we listen first of all
you cruise around the streets of where
every out with your friends and just
kids you have a gun you're not gonna get
followers yeah yeah you shouldn't your
friend yeah all right leg in follows but
you shouldn't be allowed to have a
chance you should not be allowed our
channel no it's not right and that's the
thing dude they have to have stricter
laws for people get in trying to get
facebook lock I agree because it's not
fair now I have to live with seeing this
you know now I have to know that this
some lady's shooting her friends in a
burr pool do you know in Chicago on
Facebook live there's three teenagers
that basically held hostage and beat up
a white kid I saw that yeah yeah it was
sad man it's uh it's raised and I think
they called that a hate crime it's right
oh yeah they called it a hate crime it
should be if anybody does that just
because you know either one thing I do
like it cuz that's how they got caught
if there was no Facebook live they
probably got caught that's the only good
thing those morons put on Facebook live
that's true so this all could have gone
to court we don't know who did it
everybody's denying it and then but now
we know it's a good point so I guess
it's me I wonder what happens with her
he goes to prison for being a [ __ ]
exactly if he dies but he didn't he
didn't die so if he dies before you shot
that's things don't end well oh it's so
stupid that I don't know why these
people do this but it's good that people
realize not to
thank you lost some weight no I took the
gained weight why I bro I saw that you
didn't just buy move downtown got
himself a high-rise down there really
chin he jumps up a high well no he's
renting a high res nice falling right
and then I see him on the social social
media post videos of these [ __ ]
eating Shh was it Shake Shack Shake
Shack and every day why I only went
twice but but you enjoy watching he got
two hamburgers two hot dogs who people
come to record they get addictive
American cuisine he grew up here uh I
did grow up here well but still it could
be in your genes
you just went nuts on it I think I had
it once and I was like crap it tastes so
good how much do one more time and then
chill and now you're addicted like and
this is how it starts do this twelve
steps that will get you better brother
tell them that'll set you some free dude
yeah you're out there boys doing what
can I put cheddar on next you don't say
I get too big I'll stop like three
pounds I'll stop that's how it goes they
show you 500 pounds no ballin you're on
my 600 pound life we have to fire you
it's my second I'm a producer that's
fire because I just sad to look at [ __ ]
no belt that's what your show is gonna
be below the belt no zero belt speaking
of zero Belva I don't think the guest of
the year lights didn't even get a title
I know we do need you more title best
people that reached out about a
nice-lookin bill making a belt yeah oh
really yeah yeah give us up we need to
get feel a belt get that cobbler to who
you don't want him to make shoes yeah
you know I almost in those shoes those
are worse guests yeah yeah you know we
should do we should paint those gold and
make him like the worst guess the Year
trophy skylar astin it was he in
Hamilton or something what was he in I'm
sure he's everything controls easy
really yeah voice of branch holes was so
good well that the trolls movie is
Justin Timberlake he's on the trolls
series on Netflix
oh I'm teen that still out I'm still
good really Charles movies ridiculous
though
movie so good ranch my man all right
what else got gin uh Channing Tatum and
his girl Jennifer Dhawan or Jenna Dewan
they're separating yeah they've been
together forever ever on the first step
up you guys number four step up when he
came up yeah yeah that first movie what
does it say why it's just time to move
on I guess they've been together forever
though right ever and they have kids
they have kids and all like a bunch of
couples and people like idolize their
relation forever right yeah
damn so they're breaking up do you think
he's an attractive male Theo Kenny Tatum
my girl this morning do I go man I said
this is my life you're Tatem wasn't
painting KMT yeah Jaden I said do you
think he's attractive she has basic
white boy oh my god you don't like basic
dozen I think he likes Razik he looks
like kinda like older now the
best-looking dude like you know high
school at like a Division four high
school he looks like the starting
quarterback who's like a stud and then
years later just didn't pan out yeah I
mean he looks like Johnny Manziel could
look if he got his healthiest or more
some eye shadow handsome guy I hear he's
a sweet man you ever see him in on a
[ __ ] what's that down under movie
what movie was that was shaking his dick
dick I don't watch all of that I don't
try to look at anything on the internet
what people are naked nah man there's a
movie Magic Mike Oh Magic Mike no I
didn't see that I didn't see it either
but I've seen [ __ ] Clips what I'm
saying he's bodied up so he's got a
beautiful body I think I've stopped
that's not big sister yeah see this is
something else for me this is like
something in Oklahoma over you shouldn't
have bought a ticket to it it's not like
your free ticket to the casino and you
end up at this yeah but yeah I mean look
at me in a manner you know yeah he's
that lifeguard that [ __ ] everybody in
your town there's also a nice dude yeah
yeah it's hard to win right yeah and I
mean I just I wonder what happened one
if it's just too much pressure from you
know to have a comfortable relationship
in it in Hollywood who has a
relationship in Hollywood it's even
lasted you know you know who's killing
it is Dax Shepard and his girl yeah
Kristen Bell Kristen Kristen Bell yeah
they live in Venice that's how I gonna
be the next the next one that's about
dark chin over here I think it's or next
yeah there's there's not really but Chi
Chi wrote like Frank and chin I know
right dr. Franken chin he's coming out
Count Chocula no don't don't chicken
hewlet you can't say it and don't you so
you gotta say count chin so as I was
saying is yeah they're definitely not
breaking up but she wrote a whole thing
on how to stay together like why long
she wrote like this homeless man could
he gain some well that sounds like a lot
of pressure and I will live up to that
laughs so Blake Shelton and Randall
Lambert they were also a couple that was
I idolized for their relationship yeah
Quinn so she got him first though
Miranda cheated on Blake first oh wow
yeah wow people be cheating I mean but I
think yeah that guy's gonna have a
million offers there we'll watch him
host everything coming up so he's shown
like something just watch I'm not saying
that he is the best or amazing at it I
think his Twitter used to be a lot of
funny to be a little bit more candid and
stuff well now he's on [ __ ] the voice
so it's so mange yeah now he can't yeah
but I think um and he sent out arenas
yeah and I think he's you know I think
he's really like country music but I
think he's gonna be the one that
Hollywood's like death that's the guy
that can you know help get our over
homeboy who's do homeboy on American
Idol right now he's really good to
American Idol yeah ever heard of the
coaches yeah American Idol yeah like you
just got the boat you're gonna shake and
Shack or what the [ __ ] it is you just
asked American Idol is not working hard
anymore
let's go this guy
oh look Brian right look Brian's on man
yeah I think I think he is potentially a
bigger star than your boy
who is that is that what big time real
fast is so big who's that lady that
looks like Perry is it really yeah
they're short here's a bad look
oh wow she loved her has the same
haircut different a little bit a little
bit
hers is lighter looking them you know
what Lionel Richie looks like me you
look like Katy Perry if somebody doesn't
lock up for this episode if somebody
doesn't mock up for those ever this
episode airs tomorrow our gavagai will
do that a horror or Photoshop Steve well
that's you and me range of motion in
your neck yeah bad scarf random ass
jewelry big ass DSL lips his teeth are
whiter but our nose is the same yeah I
look like Katy Perry but with somebody
else's nose though yeah well you've
carry pain across me Katy Perry and
Shrek you look like Katy Perry she [ __ ]
you up punched in the nose punch but 10
or 12 times hey well I know man Orton
right [ __ ] you're something on his
lunch break that's hanging out in the
electronics section right now like well
somebody please ring the rim the lunch
is over horn cuz this guy's doing too
much wow you do look like [ __ ] Lionel
Richie it's you and me bro and what's
wrong with uh the guy on the right he's
happy and why is this arm so long oh no
that's that's uh that's right secret no
but if that's his arm coming around LAN
over it that's what I was saying you
know ring your thing sad I got medium
linked arms dude yeah my super long
either really yeah I don't have a cankle
dick though yeah that's a good point
that's a good point it's tough yeah I'll
just mom's have never really lived up to
their potential never develop
I don't think fully I think if I to
spend
another two days in the womb boy to use
the water in the in Louisiana I think my
mom was just [ __ ] anxious and probably
wouldn't have me early ya doin stunted
your growth oh dude I knew this boy in
our town he he'll he'll I mean his mom
had him early as [ __ ] dude because they
were gonna go on vacation yeah
and she'd want to be pregnant on
vacation where they goin see rose some
[Laughter]
they gonna splash City or some yeah and
[ __ ] they're gonna have it Evansville
Indiana
I think Busch Gardens I think it was
just they were camping in their front
yard bro it's you're a shittier venue to
go the kids have Charlie Brown as their
mascot
I'll hide you Busch Gardens and of
course we didn't go there but we would
go to like we would drive to those
places and go to the other places that
were around Bush car yeah yeah like a
spicies funhouse or whatever
yeah Busch Gardens some low-level [ __ ]
that was legit yeah but now now I'm
talking about the Busch Gardens in LA
son where they have charlie Busch
Gardens is legit all those statements
but they have Sesame Street as their
mascot so it's some [ __ ] bush what
am i what I say it Knott's Berry Farm
that's very farms that [ __ ] is it's
probably way too out hang time that's a
place that sounds a racist for a water
park and be you know I don't [ __ ] with
water parks really I don't like dock
with Sox I'm like being son all goddamn
day I don't like the grown man around
the kids all together I don't like the
lazy pool it bothers me and then they
have the big wave pool which was my
favorite it gets too crowded people get
[ __ ] up I find it dangerous yeah hey
well wave pool basically just who's
gonna get rescued from your family for
real somebody always gets where a skis
your drunk uncle he thinks he can swim
they know the [ __ ] has been to the
beach you have people from you know
wherever in Colorado we call it south
shore there's a big wave pool super
dangerous we're not used to them bs ways
we're on the beach so we know how to
react to those things yeah so dudes were
getting [ __ ] yeah nah probably crying
it's a hate crime cost yeah this strong
wave is all getting us son
unbelievable once I can cuss a bunch of
caen Cassie's out there will wave pulled
out that lazy river whoever came with
that is a special [ __ ] demon
[Music]
and they didn't even clean it they're
like it's [ __ ] yes it is mrs. Texas
bro it's a real River no man Mississippi
numero uno big one though yeah but
there's a lot of other I knew is like
he's gonna go for another huge river and
these outer rivers what's the last thing
we gonna [ __ ] bath rivers people no
rivers you name five rivers not
Mississippi not the Nile not Colorado go
okay did you funked a river that's right
all right that's a report ever June okay
the [ __ ] da where's that at high in
Louisiana the Colorado River
I said no Colorado don't count your on
one right now waiting
major I'm from Colorado of course I'm in
Colorado a [ __ ] River
I want even beer okay you want a
different River yeah how about the I
have it right here
go ahead the Ohio River done what about
Z the Olin this is in Tennessee it's
called the Pittsburg yeah look at the
[ __ ] River right there rivers in the
United stop rivers and watch he'll be
the next channel creak hey the point is
here do you can [ __ ] name five well I
could name five in a second he didn't
even look him up the Ohio River River -
yeah it's boga falaya River the
Tchefuncte River the let's think of some
other ones let's think of some other
ones the thing is it's hard no it isn't
dude think of another one damn you
that's a real River yeah he knows his
rivers why no more rivers than two
rivers in one of them's in Africa the
Nile the cradle of civilization' River
you only know like rivers that were
either in the Bible or the Mississippi
river Euphrates at a river yes
it goes Bible rivers that's all hey no
bro he's got the Nile
[ __ ] yeah but now he said me copy it
again I'm surprised yeah I'm surprised
Mekong River the Kama River the way we
got here though I was just saying that
those [ __ ] water parts are [ __ ]
yeah they are what else you got chin you
want to do the wolf arrow one sure so
will Ferrell and walking Phoenix I guess
will fair I was interviewing Joaquin
Phoenix how great have you read this
interview someone sent this to me
yesterday I tweeted it Will Ferrell
conducted an interview by phone to
Joaquin Phoenix and they don't know each
other
it was [ __ ] hilarious Wow cuz Will
Ferrell was trying to be serious at
first I want Joaquin Phoenix's like yo
man how bad our interviews to do and
welfare was like hold on I'm getting
started and then he goes they like talk
about sports and one key thing cuz I
didn't know the superball was on someone
told me to click to it because there was
a good game so I saw the last seconds I
don't know anything about it Will
Ferrell goes yeah I just watch cuz my
kids hey and he goes hey you live in LA
and what King goes yeah and we'll goes
dude I'm sure we live close next time we
have a sporting event we always have
people you should come over and Joaquin
Phoenix like no I don't want to do that
that's it he's like no I'm not doing
that and welfare of those damn just like
that in Joaquin's like yeah man I'm sick
of making excuses I'm a grown man and I
usually make excuse not to show up to
things but then I just stopped
straight-up tell people no I'm not doing
it and Will's like God I like that man
and then they keep going and what in
Phoenix is like yeah these interviews
are all the same and then we'll feel
flips the page goes no not really
hey do you remember we did gladiator
he's like gays like Romero near that
little [ __ ]
he's all yeah he's like yeah I like that
role for you it was great man it was
[ __ ] great Wow oh no I want to read
this so I was laughing my long I was
laughing my car watching Matt no a
phenomenal interview and you can tell
they don't know each other huh they
don't know each other's will goes we saw
each other at one time and I was like
hey I'm a fan and he's like and you're
like cool in what kings like I don't
remember any of that so they don't know
each other and then what's playing on
social media while Kings like man I
don't get this social media thing I got
on Twitter for a day and he was the next
one I thought I don't want to have to
come up with SH every day to post on
Twitter so he's like I don't it doesn't
exist for me at all yeah weirdos yeah I
just had a meeting with my team he's
calling this team
is that a meeting with my team and they
were like hey you need to do more social
media and we'll goes if I have to do
more social media I'm leaving the
business Wow yeah yeah I don't want to
do that man which is interesting
they're at a level we can do that though
I feel like yeah I guess I mean yeah I
mean Will Ferrell's one of a kind
Joaquin Phoenix is one of a kind he
played Johnny Cash right yeah hell yeah
yes we could do everyone's dude yeah I
mean there's a yeah I mean there's got
it five to me right now yeah you know
you retired from acting like a little
bit ago in cities and become a rapper
he's going through some [ __ ] yeah he
might have owned it could have been
bipolar it could have been just LA this
place a haunt this place a wreck your
brain but you read that never you can
his insecurities are crazy he's like
yeah they offer him this role my god
they should offer it to someone else I'm
gonna [ __ ] this movie up and no feels
like well you're a brilliant actor you
know that right he's like he's like well
I don't know your taste you could have
shitty tastes and actors and movies it
was like now I kind of know my [ __ ] he's
like well I always think there's better
people for the role well that's when
wills like no you're Creighton gladiator
he's a go yeah what you like great is
you're that little [ __ ] he was a little
bit he was great yeah um what else is
going on is gonna be a New Jersey man
for what comedy we're yeah that a couple
weeks Hasbrouck Heights have you been
there no bananas there's an almond
Anna's comedy called bananas comedy I've
never been did you see oh we want to
either go ahead and lay your dates one
either oh oh yeah I am there in two
weeks man or three weeks actually that's
April 20th and 21st I'll be a bananas
comedy in New Jersey
Friday Saturday Friday and Saturday
socials Friday to zero Saturday two
shows Friday to Saturday I told you I
was in San Jose improv and I was a young
it feel everywhere I go my guys got your
Theo here man thanks man they got from
San Jose is like yeah get us in contact
with them so I could definitely do that
yeah I'd love to gotta let you over
there to San Jose San Jose is the most
diverse place I've ever been I think
it's nots right yeah it's like
everything it's almost perfectly diverse
it's like oh this is what America will
be like and you know in the future we
know it's the most expensive place I
think it'd just be not Manhattan for
most spensive so really property so do
people got money out there well yet so
it's Silicon Valley so you got Facebook
and all that [ __ ] there and
they're not building more houses so the
housing markets nuts like that just like
2.2 million
Wow yeah and we should have got uh we
should got land up there or so you know
New Jersey where else you going yeah
wasn't gonna be a Cherokee Casino in
June on June 9th
where's Cherokee is it it's in Cherokee
Casino is out there outside of Oklahoma
City about 50 minutes I feel like I've
been there you might have oh yeah well
river is that I wanted to tell you so no
the Oklahoma River and that'll be a
Calgary and yuk-yuk you're going there
you want are you there I'm June 15th and
16th AM I'm April oh man or 2 weeks
yeah man leap saw at least some room up
there on the stage for me huh get it out
of here and I'll go up there - Tim blur
brewing and it's out in Bakersfield
dude I'm there Friday are you really
yeah damn bro do we have the same agent
so Doug I'm June 23rd
are you CAA yeah oh me too uh uh Andy
fair egg that little Egyptian guy
beautiful guys oh yeah he's great yeah
he's got a little easy good and he's not
a junk just little it's a lot of other
things about him but if you see him you
wouldn't notice he's smaller Egyptian
man they probably got that short
probably been to the [ __ ] those rivers
but now some of those Euphrates some of
his Bible stops he's probably taking a
dip I've got a short ears
cuz I come from me hearing people judge
your tell yeah that's exactly bad dude
you filled in pretty good for a count
today man no makes you laugh harder
brother oh thanks man I was having me
and it's good to see you chin and thanks
so much for you guys support the
reigning champ the reigning champ no
belt we run out we're gonna ma got about
hey yo if you listen this and you guys
know we're can get a cool belt for the
gutters of the year let's count on
breaks over there to Brendan's breaks
you just set me up with your bar
everyone caught even dude you got to see
my buddy has this new show is called but
party right it's gonna be on YouTube and
it's basically somebody just judging
people's farts right it's oh wow it's
terrible - awesome man
I saw anyway I've seen their thing we
didn't take it that though you get my
tickets at theof on calm slash tour tou
R and the dark art store will be
launching on next week probably you
probably your Instagram to you post on
there have a bunch of new new dates yeah
we put it on there what's your Instagram
just at Theo von th EO vo in that's easy
and I'll see you guys in Tampa this
weekend actually but I think it's
already sold out Tampa improv yeah I
know
doing my own place called the Attic at
Rock Brothers brewing I was just in Tim
Tim are you we're the same
I was at the improv they're a great
place yeah that's that three story place
yeah big boy yeah that's cool maybe in
the future we'll do that but you
definitely will learning as we go
I hear you but I mean the old studio man
they'd like ghosts in there a lot of
girls a lot of fire to ghost yeah
somebody left eyeliner in there too I
got really good Jared Leto one point and
Luther mind but whatever those boots are
somebody here someone's these are
biblical actually yeah those are
straight off the set of Game of Thrones
um I'll be this Friday I'm in
Bakersfield I think that is sold out but
check tickets now f FK DICOM and then in
two weeks the 20th 21st I'm at yuk-yuks
Calgary and those tickets are going fast
two of those shows are sold out so tea
fat K calm for tickets and Wednesday
night were released in the mr. OWL
tootsie roll teas it's right XTO there
how many licks does it take to before I
bust and that's your that's your shirt
so is it really not your shirt oh that's
Correctional Center blue - yes calm this
is the fighter and the Vaughn were out
bust